hums gum resumes welcome back to
navigate nad there's a few things that
we missed in the last episode so I
thought we were gonna check them out
together brace so I don't let it and
Jake the dog and yeah we'll check them
all out eventually but I want to check
out Jake looks so good
Wow okay hey Jake Jake watch out the
Hickok good job Jake come on grab your
friend this looks fantastic
oh my God he's walking through twerking
that's something I always wanted a girl
you want your mommy I am your mommy tell
me her baby oh that's very good
Galla beck says all right we're normal
good it's all fine
oh it's a skate park oh my god can I go
to the skate board please are to use it
said oh my god what this game would just
become the best game ever yeah what if I
go up don't allow me to [ __ ] away from
me back off [ __ ] okay ow there we go oh
my god this is so hardcore whoa oh god
what happened to my head let's go baby
bring it front flip what the [ __ ] what
is happening now the best skate oh my
god I don't know how to push really yes
this makes sense good job coach I know
buddy run faster what what how did I do
that
yeah oh my god oh Jesus what no what do
you doing goat
what are you doing there we go fantastic
Beth
bicycle simulator sense bicycle
simulator I'm stopped yeah I'll go to
unlocked oh my god oh I have to wall
jump to get up there cool alright let's
see if I can do it now oh my god the
skills alright this is gonna be hard man
parkour God's power come on baby that's
how we do it that's how it's done
that's how we jump no what oh thank god
got that job [ __ ] oh there's a potty
here
hey man what yeah what the hell did he
eat freaking dynamite
Oh God Oh God use your parkour skills
use your yes we're fine Jesus is that
ice Batman fans must have been on fire
what is his bicycle challenge yes please
the hell why would he write me well I
what if that doesn't make any sense why
would he write me Oh God okay okay okay
it's so hard it's really hard
why is he humping Lance Armstrong might
have been like balls but I like a goat
wait oh no way
you know your own drugs if you see
something like this in real life okay
there we go we did it almost there we go
nailed it I'm so proud of myself
whoa what's going on down here well that
looks spooky what what oh oh god oh god
oh god
it's Leonard ouch no let him he needs
leakage I'm licking goat he likes it he
just needs a better love that's all he
needs
Oh God slender God make love to me
please oh no pet died here
Oh No anyone but pet they really did a
good job modeling him because he looks
really hot
Oh God and you sound even kinkier baby
let me ride you let me love you tonight
I'm bringing him with me you're my new
best friend Slendy she stuck to
something
oh god what are you doing slender God
slender god what did I tell you calm
down you need to calm down right now
you're not a balloon slender man you're
not but oh he calmed down finally which
one do you wanna go on fire Slendy oh my
god I having the best time right now
Slendy I just try to save it I think I
love you
we've been together now for nearly 2
minutes and I think it's time that I pop
the question where does his head go
that's thick that is the question what
is that no don't leave me slender gosh
sandy got new that's how your couch good
job good job on that couch bra that's
how you couch right there that's the
best couch ever seen
yes I've seen some quality stuff but
this this is wins it all right
best goat ever seriously oh my God he's
six acts like a boss
hi guys a skull on you never seen a crab
before yeah that's right you never seen
a skateboarding crab before no you got a
problem with me you got a problem with
this skate put up your lace nailed it
do a 360 Tony Hawk's skate spin got it
look at this only that holy like ride
that front over I got a roll alright
let's gather [ __ ] maybe the escape other
thing isn't for me after uh-oh let's go
inside the suit oh you can't go inside
I knew that disgusting ill what that's
good I like it
I'm making me wanna dance there yeah
yeah yeah does anyone have a limp death
[ __ ] I ya doing here ah I come in peace
fight me in real life bro head bed
Michael Bay turtle Michael betta the
Michael Bay titles that my lace favorite
type of paddles screw this Michael play
nonsense oh no I could there's no escape
there we go I'm free from the michael
curse thank god
so I look like a goat I'm a crab god
damn it get with the times it's time to
party breast your press ready walk in
the club like what's up hey how's
everyone doing yeah
damn famous dance dance [ __ ] you all
I have deadmau5 goat I got dead mouse on
my dick
what just face I got dead master oh god
that looks awesome yeah that's fantastic
oh god where am i lighting no not here
ow
ow come on [ __ ] get on top oh yeah she
liked to ride it baby oh yeah that's
good
oh hey she loved it she loves to ride
that deep jump bail that she took my
[ __ ]
come back here ah what is she doing
don't be hating come back here what the
[ __ ] is wrong with what the hell are you
doing right now some people just can't
handle it
oh it's a boy this side yeah whatever
still partying all right bruh it's gonna
have to end that episode here go ahead
and leave a like if you want more goat
simulator and you enjoy watching that's
always thank you for us so much for
watching
it's this guy - cumbria today and I'll
see you tomorrow thousand